okay well yeah um yeah thank you for
having me uh to kind of speak to you
today um
yeah my name's ross uh i'm coming to uh
coming from uh deepmind science team
and yeah today we're gonna be talking
about uh the work done with alpha fold
which you may have heard of which is our
way of our method for solving the
protein structure prediction problem
um
yeah and so we're going to cover some
background on proteins because yeah i i
won't assume that anyone knows uh you
know what proteins are or how they work
or why they're interesting
uh so we'll do a bit of background on
proteins and the physics of that and
then dive into some of the
machine learning components that make
alpha fold work um yeah and chat about
them a bit uh and yeah maybe then later
look into some of the results and uh
interpretation of that and some of the
impact uh yeah and i think alpha fold is
a super interesting case study for i
guess what you've been uh learning about
already
because i guess it's it's a sort of
non-standard machine learning um
architecture but also incorporates these
ideas of sort of geometric deep learning
which i know you've
been learning about
and and yeah and it's also it's also
something that has
had an example of deep learning that's
had practical uh impact out in the in
the real world so i think they're always
the most interesting things to to learn
about
oh yeah and uh please feel free to
interrupt with questions but i'll try
and leave some time at the end
otherwise
cool so uh yeah i think we'll first
start by talking about proteins in
general and why they're interesting and
why we would like to use machine
learning to to learn about them
um so yeah to first start by explaining
what really proteins are is you should
bring i'm sure everyone's heard the word
protein we should frame it as uh you
know if an organism wants to do
something within its cells or within the
body generally how they'll do that is by
having a protein which is specialized to
that task so really you can think of
them as these little
molecular machines that are essential
for life and for doing all sorts of the
the processes
um so but and and really these processes
can span all sorts of things so for
example it might be structural so you
know it might be making up your hair or
something or it could be to do with your
immune system even so i'm sure more
recently everyone's heard around the
sort of the coronavirus lots of talk
around the the spike protein and this is
a protein of the virus which is
important for sort of gaining access to
a to a cell so proteins are really
important for all these different kinds
of
functions across life
and yeah proteins are large molecules
obviously made up of atoms
but in a sort of higher level of
abstraction of that they're these long
chains of amino acids and we're talking
to what what that means exactly but so
we can imagine a big long chain of amino
acids almost like beads on a string
and uh due to physics the forces of
physics these things will jiggle around
and fold up until they create some kind
of
3d molecule of the kind you can see on
the slides here
and so this exact 3d shape which the
protein ends up folding into
uh determines things relating to the the
function of the
protein and yeah so for example what it
what it might do and what its purpose
might be
so yeah to expand on this idea of uh
proteins as a
collection of amino acids we can we can
dive into what that means and so so we
have all these uh little um
these molecules which is sort of
connected together one after another as
i say like forming a string and so if
we're thinking like computer scientists
we can imagine that we can describe a
protein basically as a string
of letters
in an alphabet of 20 or sometimes 21
that being the sort of the number of
different amino acids so we can almost
think of it as like a
like a word where each letter designates
an amino acid and they're sort of
ordered and connected together like that
and you should also be thinking that um
this is pretty much what your dna sort
of encodes for so some section of your
dna
a gene is basically going to tell you
the recipe for what order together to
put together some amino acids to make a
a specific protein
uh and yeah um
but so so what is it that actually makes
these uh these amino acids that make up
the protein what is it that actually
makes them different and why uh why like
why is it meaningful to have different
orders of amino acids
and and the reason for that is that all
of the amino acids are made up of
different
collections of atoms they're sort of
slightly uh different
molecules and so as you can see on this
uh on this slide on this poster
here's examples of all of the different
possible amino acids and they all have
different uh
uh chemical properties let's say so some
of them maybe sort of uh have
been electrically charged or some of
them might be um
uh hydrophobic so they really dislike
being in contact with water
and also you can see from here that they
have sort of
quite drastically different sizes just
in the kind of the number of atoms
almost so you can see that tryptophan in
the bottom right
has these really big
loops of these rings
uh whereas alanine in the bottom left is
really quite small so um yeah this is
not even going to give sort of physical
constraints of where these molecules
want to go
and so as i said the
the the amino acids will all sort of uh
link together in a in a line almost so
we have this this chain of amino acids
and they all connect together along this
single this sort of shared backbone that
they all have
uh running along the middle and the
differences are actually in what's
called the side chains and these are
these uh all the
these different kinds of these different
kinds of atoms sort of hanging off the
backbone
and what gives the different amino acids
their different uh these different uh
chemical properties
and so if you imagine this is kind of
what a uh what a protein would look like
if you just had a protein that had one
of each different kind of amino acids
you kind of have this contiguous
backbone which connects together in a
chain all the way along
and then you have these the different
side chains hanging off
where so for example histidine has a
certain side chain and cysteine has a
has a different one
and yeah when this these will fold up to
create uh different 3d molecules
and and yeah and the the 3d molecules
which the 3d shape which the the protein
folds up to form is exactly what we want
to try and predict with with alpha fold
and um yeah and why do we want to try
and predict that why can't we just sort
of measure it scientifically
and the reason for that is we do have
ways of trying to measure this
scientifically they're just extremely uh
difficult and uh time consuming they can
take months or even years to solve the
structure of a single protein
and that's because the the methods which
which can do this for example things
like x-ray crystallography
uh have many stages and many ways in
which things can go wrong
so for example if i had a new protein i
wanted to solve the structure of say for
example some
yeah the hemoglobin uh
and i wanted to learn its learning
structure i would have to go through all
of these steps on here i would need to
make some dna that codes for the protein
i would need to put it into some cells
maybe some yeast or some e coli
only to grow those cells so it produces
the protein i need to smash the cells up
to sort of extract the insides uh purify
the protein so i only have my protein of
interest and not all of the other
proteins that are going on inside the
cell i then need to sort of grow these
crystals which is famously difficult to
do
so crystal's a pure protein
then i can do what's called
x-ray diffraction using some sort of
high energy uh
x-rays usually
what's called a synchrotron
again very expensive and difficult uh
and then interpret the data and then
maybe at the end but then i now can
solve the protein structure from that
but there's a lot of different steps and
and can be very difficult so what we
would like to do is basically skip all
of those steps uh with machine learning
and just go from step one
straight to step eight and predict the
the protein structure in in
so that's what we're going to try and do
but as you'll know um we can't do
machine learning without data
so we need data to to learn from and
train our models and but luckily the the
structural biology community
has been collecting this data for a long
time
running these really difficult
experiments and solving the 3d structure
of many many proteins
it's not the world's largest training
set of all time but there is something
like 200 000 solved protein structures
out there
and very conveniently they're all nicely
logged away in what's called the protein
data bank the pdb
and yeah the community has been really
good in um
making all of this data publicly
available for anyone to do research on
which is really great um
from a sort of uh yeah machine learning
point of view to have access to all of
this data
yeah so this is the sort of starting
point for us of what is our training set
and it's the 200 000 protein structures
that have already been solved by uh by
the community
um
so
uh yeah often already in this in this
deck i think we've um
shown some uh illustrations of the 3d
structures of proteins
uh but obviously these aren't things
that you can see with your naked eye
they're sort of down at the atomic scale
and so the visualizations are always
going to be a bit of a
representation and there's always a few
different ways of showing these
so on the left hand side you can see
the visualization of the protein
with all of the atoms visualized uh so
the the lines between the sort of
blobs the green blue and red
uh spheres are all individual atoms and
the lines between them are showing bonds
between the atoms and so in some senses
it's sort of showing everything
but in other sense it's very hard to
pass this
um
you know it just looks like a big blob
of atoms it doesn't seem to be that much
structure inside it
so commonly what people will do which is
this picture on in the middle is just
show this sort of uh cartoon
representation of the protein uh which
is just showing the the backbone and
ignoring all of the side chains and in
this one we can quite clearly see or
much more clearly see but it's in fact
is like a string uh a single string
that's folded up
and also what we can see is some common
motifs so for example we see these uh
these helices
which called alpha helices and we can
see some of the these arrows um
which are there as well which get called
beta strands or beta sheets and these
are sort of common motifs that often are
made up of proteins but obviously it's
just a sort of artist's impression
basically
uh and yeah and i think this this um
this middle representation is what we'll
tend to uh be looking at most commonly
and obviously on the right we've just
got the two uh overlaid over each other
so they're kind of showing the same
thing just with different levels of
detail
cool and then
it's important for us to think about uh
what are the different causal
relationships in uh
in in sort of thinking about proteins
because it happens on a few different
levels
so we're currently thinking about the
protein being defined by its amino acid
sequence
as we've said this like this chain of
amino acids and the order in which they
exist on the chain and so that's sort of
one level to think about it
but we know that when that gets turned
into a protein sort of when your body
actually makes it
we end up with this
3d structure 3d molecule
and it's there's a sort of causal
relationship there that the physics sort
of causes that molecule to take on a
certain shape
but obviously then that molecule then
has a role within uh within your body so
for example it might uh you know as i
said it might be making your hair
and then how strong your hair is might
actually be important for you as an
organism or it might be to do with your
immune system and how intact your immune
system is might uh affect how successful
an organism is so this obviously then uh
affects uh evolution at a species level
so having a protein which is kind of
gone wrong or has a a mutation in it
could fundamentally affect the
sort of trajectory of how this species
goes on to evolve
and that's actually a key insight which
we can use in protein structure
prediction
because we can look at what is the um
the evolutionary history of a single
protein
and we can actually use that to infer
back in the other direction to try and
learn something about the structure and
i'll try and uh explain some intuition
around how that works uh yeah on the
next slide
so
yeah if you see these sort of little
cartoons let's say about about the
sequence where we imagine the sort of
the different the various different
arrows or different
amino acids
we can kind of think of the sequence
that a protein has so for example again
let's think of say hemoglobin
but we can think of the hemoglobin
sequence in lots of different species so
in like humans or cats or dogs
and so all of these are going to be kind
of evolutionary even evolutionarily
related
and that means they're all going to be
quite similar and hopefully are all
going to do the same thing inside the
body but the sequences all might uh vary
quite slightly just due to you know
random mutation and evolution
uh but if we look through the sequences
we might notice that certain mutations
seem to happen uh
seem to happen sort of uh
uh in tandem with each other so for
example these these uh sorry i don't
have a pointer i don't think do i have a
pointer uh oh yeah maybe hopefully
hopefully you can see this pointer
um
so these um these sort of these two
green
green guys here
uh at some point in the other species
switch to these red guys but if i look
over at this position these red guys
switch to green guys and that could just
be random chance but it could be the
fact as we see here that in the 3d
structure
these two amino acids are interacting
with each other and so if one mutates
the other one has to mutate sort of to
accommodate for that
uh so there can be some signal which
says that um
yeah if if if amino acids tend to mutate
together in in evolution then they might
be they must be sort of related to each
other in the in the 3d structure of the
protein and we can use that signal to
or we can hopefully use that signal to
try and
deduce something about the structure
when we're trying to predict it using
using alpha fold
cool so hopefully that was uh
a uh useful but whistle stop
introduction to proteins and what we're
trying to do here
uh now i'm going to talk about the
actual machine learning side of things
so how we're going to use deep learning
and ideas from geometric deep learning
and all sorts of things
to try and build a model that can take
the sequence of amino acids of a protein
and try and predict its 3d structure so
literally try and predict xyz
coordinates of all the atoms in the
protein so it can give us one of these
uh these nice uh 3d models
so as you'll know like when we're
thinking about deep learning and
different neural network architectures
there's all sorts of different
considerations uh for different types of
models and they all have different
inductive biases aka they're all sort of
designed for different types of data and
baking in different
sort of symmetries or whatnot
um and so yeah we have uh convolutional
networks which i guess we usually think
of in computer vision so we're thinking
about data that exists on a
on a grid for example a regular grid and
the information flow might be between
neighboring pixels uh and
yeah
which makes a lot of sense for images
for example and that was actually the
basis of alpha fold one the original
version
of this model
uh we also can think of recurrent
networks like rnns or
lstms uh and
these are usually for thinking about
data in ordered sequences whether
they're kind of a progression of time or
causality
and in some ways that makes a bit of
sense for proteins because we're
thinking about things in uh in you know
an ordered list almost but actually i
think this information flow only going
in one direction kind of doesn't doesn't
fit our problem too nicely
um yeah we can also think of things like
graph networks um
yeah which i i imagine you you might you
might have come across um
which uh yeah we can think about the
information flow similar to in a
convolutional neural network but over a
more sort of general
graph topology
uh and yeah that makes a lot of sense
for proteins because we have this sort
of weird
spatial graph almost but the problem is
we don't know what the spatial graph is
until we've predicted it and that's the
sort of the problem we're trying to
solve so we're kind of presupposing the
problem there
uh and yeah finally we have these sort
of uh attention-based architectures uh
like used in language in in transformers
and here we're thinking about the data
as being a sort of unordered set of
entities
uh which all may want to communicate
with each other and whether or not they
do communicate with each other is is
this kind of uh dynamically uh driven
process through our uh
key and query attention uh which is sort
of learnt and dynamically updated
throughout the network
uh and i think that really fits uh that
really fits the the problem
uh the the best as far as far as we're
concerned
so we think about um
which of these fits onto the domain of
proteins
firstly we want an end to end system
which can kind of take in an amino acid
sequence so basically language
as an input
and can produce 3d xyz coordinates as an
output that's already kind of a weird
setup for uh deep learning so we're
already going to have to do something
a bit random
uh but but yeah thinking about those
inductive biases uh we we want residues
which are close to each other in space
sorry i should clarify when i say
residues
i i mean that interchangeably with amino
acids so essentially these individual
entities which make up the protein i'd
call them either amino acids or residues
um so yeah we kind of want to
de-emphasize the fact that only
neighbors can speak to each other
because really sort of the protein can
like bend round and different bits can
all be in contact with each other so we
kind of want to
have a dynamic way of communication to
happen like that so attention sounds
perfect
um we also want to
reason quite a lot about sort of pairs
of amino acids so how this and this
interact with each other
so we often start thinking about things
in terms of this uh this this this
pairwise representation
so um
so how does
how does residue i communicate with
residue j
and this starts looking a bit like say
like an affinity matrix for for a graph
so it's not too dissimilar to sort of
graph neural networks in that sense
okay so i want to do a quick run through
of what the sort of
uh yeah the
entire system looks like for alpha fold
uh
but yeah this might be a bit a bit
whistle stop again
so as i mentioned we first have the um
the the input sequence the amino acid
sequence which is what comes in at the
at the very bottom
um and yeah we talked a bit about the um
the ability to use evolutionary history
or genetics to
um to infer something about the
structure so in order to do that we
first take the initial input sequence
and look up in some genetics databases a
whole set of sequences which we think
might be evolutionary related to our to
our protein of interest uh yeah we can
do that with existing tools for the sort
of database lookups and ideally for our
initial input sequence we'll find
say 30 to 100 or or more
related sequences
and that can kind of be the the proper
input to our network
then as i said we want to initialize
not just a sort of
uh a feature for each input sequence um
for each input residue
but actually a feature for each pair of
each pair of residues so rather than
sort of n input residues we have n
squared pairs of residues
this is going to be our pairwise feature
and then kind of as an additional input
sometimes we'll look up for if any
if we think there's any similar proteins
to this that have already been solved
and we can use that as kind of clues for
the network to to work on but i think
that's uh that's the less important part
of the of the architecture
yeah so so so as i said we have these
two different representations one of
them is to do with the
the the evolutionary history that's what
we'll call the msa but a multiple
sequence alignment
and the other is to do with the pair
representation and that's going to tell
us something about the structure of the
protein so
how does how do each pair of residues
relate to one another
and and and actually what we want to do
is obviously you want to be taking
information from here which we know
exists sort of hidden in this data and
we want to be sort of feeding it into
this which is our hypothesis about uh
how the structure looks or yeah or what
uh yeah what the 3d structure of this
protein is and trying to sort of decode
that from this
then finally once we so yeah we put this
through a very deep neural network which
we call evoformer it's a kind of
transformer
and then ultimately these feature
representations which are still sort of
abstract features go into what we call
the structure module which is where
these abstract features get converted to
something
concrete an actual 3d structure that you
might recognize as a protein something
with xyz coordinates
which we could say is a is a protein
and yeah a final sort of interesting
thing we we came across in developing
this is that we're actually able to um
take our final predictions from the
network and then kind of feed them back
in at the beginning of the network again
and sort of ask the network to to try
again and to sort of iterate on it
iterate on its own prediction and see if
it can improve it and we call that
recycling and it's actually quite a
general trick and it actually seems to
work pretty well
um it um you can you can i guess you can
think of it as a sort of sneaky way to
make your network deeper uh because
you're really just sort of stacking
multiple versions of the network
together
uh but yeah
i i probably won't go much further into
that
oh yeah and then another thing we we
produce as well as um
the
as well as the um the structure itself
is we ask the network to
estimate its own uncertainty or predict
its own loss
which we can actually use as a measure
of confidence and i think this is
another general uh
thing that you could use in other
domains which actually works
surprisingly well it's kind of
surprising that the network would be
particularly good at estimating its own
uncertainty
but uh yeah it seems to work uh very
nicely so we actually use this as a kind
of confidence measure for our
predictions like how how well does the
network think that it's done
okay so now uh i want to dive slightly
more uh
a bit more technically into what is it
and what do one what do each of these
layer individual layers do because we
talked about how it's kind of like
uh a transformer-like architecture but
what is uh what does that mean so i'll
dive into the sort of main layer of the
network which is we call the evo former
so as i mentioned we have these two
different sort of parallel tracks of
features we have the msa feature and the
powerwise feature and these are actually
going to update each other update
themselves via self-attention
uh so i i i
i'm not i'm not sure if you've uh
covered much on sort of transformer
based architectures before
but yeah we maybe don't have time to go
into it um so much in this talk
unfortunately
but uh yeah these features are basically
gonna sort of update themselves via
self-attention but also we have some
novel mechanism by which the we can sort
of crosstalk these features so while the
msa feature is doing self-attention on
itself we can kind of bias that process
by our current understanding of the
structure here so we can sort of imagine
the information is crossing across the
streams
and we can also do the exact same thing
in the in the other direction and if
anyone wants any would like any more
details on uh yeah exactly how this
process works maybe uh yeah we could we
could cover it in the questions
um but for now we can kind of think of
it as
yeah these channels are both updating
themselves through self-attention but
there's kind of a crosstalk mechanism
between the two of them and yeah in
order to make one compatible with the
other we have a sort of an
out-of-product operation here
yeah and then uh the the pairwise
feature which is yeah trying to
represent the structure as we've as
we've uh established
uh then goes on to refine itself through
what we call the uh triangular
interactions and i'm going to dive into
that a bit more because i think that's
one of the more interesting
contributions of the the alpha fold
paper is a sort of uh and and also i
think interesting for this course
because it's very sort of geometrically
motivated
uh
right so yeah i think the triangular
operations we have here in offal is one
of the key architectural uh
uh contributions of the paper and really
we're sort of taking something that's
working entirely on abstract feature
space like self-attention and trying to
reinforce that it's talking about some
spatial things so it's about
3d objects in space
what that means is that we need some
notion of consistency
so if all of these entities represent
relationships between two pairs of
objects then ultimately they all have to
be self-consistent with each other so
for example if you look at this if this
if if this element represents this green
arrow going from
a to b
and this element represents this red
arrow going from b to c
and that kind of constrains what this
element should be telling us about
because that's supposed to take us from
c back to a and in a sort of consistent
world uh these things are all sort of
self-constraining you can imagine
something like the triangle inequality
that gives us some bounds on
on these kinds of things or even if you
if you know the vector
directly then you're sort of fully
constrained
yeah but um
so so so in order to create this um sort
of cycle consistency we have a couple of
different mechanisms
one of them we call uh triangular
attention
uh
so if you imagine if we're doing regular
self-attention
and uh yeah and this residue this this
entity is attending to this one
there's actually a third
edge that's being missed from this
calculation which is this one so we
basically have a mechanism to sort of in
all of our pairwise attention operations
to sort of incorporate this third
missing edge into the into the equation
uh so to sort of make sure that it's
always being considered in in terms of
cycles
uh then we have another one which we
call the triangle multiplication
which basically averages embeddings
for a given edge over all of the length
three cycles which is a part of
uh and yeah i think the intuition for
this can be kind of tricky so um
i would if you're interested i'd highly
recommend looking at the um the
supplementary information in in the
alpha fold paper because um yeah i think
there's some quite nice explanations of
what's going on here and yeah
uh yeah thinking about how how this
enforces some spatial consistency
uh
yeah so so the next thing i wanted to
talk about is um
what we call the structure module so
this is the part of the network which
it takes the abstract feature vectors
that we talked about
and transforms them actually into
physical 3d
uh coordinates
so really a concrete realization of a
protein
now as we've said the the amino acids in
the protein backbone are sort of
contiguous and connected together to
form a chain
uh but we actually don't ever tell the
network about that we basically just say
okay here's a set of amino acids and you
can sort of uh orient them as a as a
translation and a rotation to sort of
form like a reference frame
uh in space
uh and then basically give the network
the free
the ability to sort of freely move all
these things around in space
uh and sort of place them
to form the protein and this is how we
sort of create this 3d structure by uh
taking this sort of gas of of residues
and allowing the network to assemble
them and iteratively update them that's
what you can kind of see in this
animation is the
is the network's attempt at making the
structure sort of being iteratively
improved
uh in uh in terms of thinking about the
sort of geometric side of things uh
because each residue has not just a
position but a whole reference frame
uh we can do all operations of our
spatial attention
uh in in the sort of local reference
frame of each residue
and uh yeah this naturally gives us a
sort of uh yeah sa3 equivalent um
transformer without the sort of um yeah
i know there's
quite a few different other variants of
uh these invariant transformers uh
around now but so this is how we've done
it by uh basically just doing everything
in in the local reference frame for each
residue uh which is a nice property
uh and yeah so this uh this is the stage
of the network that kind of iteratively
updates and refines the the protein
structure into something that we
recognize as a protein
uh
yeah and yeah i won't dwell on this too
much just because in the interest of
time
but uh another thing that we did is try
to make use of lots of the um
the the unlabeled data we have so as
as well as having 200 000
uh solved protein structures we also
have uh
millions and millions even billions of
uh protein sequences for which we don't
know the structure
and we want to know if we could actually
make use of that for training so we used
what's called a noisy student
self-distillation
and what that means is we train an
initial model based on just all of the
labeled data
so the 200 000 protein structures
then what we can do is we can take that
trained model
and make predictions on all of the
unlabeled data so basically try and
predict labels for all of the unlabeled
data
and because we have our
confidence estimates for the network we
can say we can take just the really
confident predictions from
all the unlabeled data and then retrain
a model using
using this much bigger training set
uh and obviously the data isn't as high
quality because it's predicted uh but we
actually found this uh helped us in uh
yeah in training a much better much
better model
and yeah uh yeah you can find uh these
these figures in in the paper but
actually uh
rather than there being a sort of single
idea that really helps the performance
of alphavolt it's really uh the sort of
sum total of lots of different ideas i
think that's a useful learning for lots
of different sort of machine learning
systems that lots of different ideas can
uh can compose
cool and so we've talked about it a bit
in a sort of theoretical sense sort of
how does our fold work but it can be
quite interesting to take a look at what
the network's actually doing throughout
all of the different layers
so in order to do that we we looked at
you know this big stack of 48
transformer layers and thought
what's the network's best guess at the
protein structure at each each
individual layer and sort of ask it to
predict a structure after each layer in
the network and you can see some really
interesting things this is like as you
go through the depth of the network
what's the best guess of the this this
protein structure and you see it's
really trying lots of different things
until it converges on on
on on the correct answer actually after
after hundreds of layers
and even for some really big proteins
you can see there's a there's quite a
lot of variability happening
quite deep into the network and
obviously right at the start you start
with something that doesn't look like a
protein at all
uh but
yeah you see lots of sort of coordinated
movement uh and always it sort of looks
like a real protein more or less which i
think is quite interesting
um yeah and yeah another thing we
observe is that as you go through the
network
the accuracy pretty much always gets
better which is what you'd expect
but you notice you you often make as you
see with the green line here
uh the network often makes some uh some
you know some some discoveries more or
less some big hops up in accuracy where
it sort of figured out something better
and pretty much never pretty much never
sort of gives those accuracy gains up
which i think is quite quite interesting
cool um so
now i'd like to talk quickly about um
some of the some of the results we had
and how we knew we'd sort of built uh
quite a good system
uh and yeah how we sort of evaluated
this after after all the training
so the main way in which we evaluated
the model when we thought we had
something that was good was we entered
what's called casp the critical
assessment of protein structure
prediction and this is a blind
assessment that happens every two years
for the protein structure prediction
community
and it's pretty much impossible to cheat
on which is great
because you submit your predictions for
a protein structure and then they
actually go away and solve the protein
after you've submitted your prediction
so there's
there's kind of no way you can cheat
which is really great
um
and uh yeah we so we came away from this
with a really great set of results which
we uh
yeah which we believed were actually
competitive with experiment
according to the the casper organizers
which is really amazing and so we
uh we're pretty sure that we had
something that would be very useful for
the community
so so went ahead with trying to yeah
open source the model so that this model
is fully out there open source anyone
can pick it up and use it for free even
for commercial applications
uh and published a paper on it
but we also uh
know that not everyone has the sort of
the resources or the time or the ability
to
uh to run all of these predictions
themselves
so we've released a giant database of
predicted structures
uh and yeah this is what we call the the
alpha fold database and it's currently
online you can look up all sorts of
proteins
and find our predictions for them
at the moment we have the full set of
proteins for
21 organisms so i think there's maybe
about a million proteins there currently
but very shortly we'll be updating it to
approximately 100 million new proteins
so that's going to be very exciting and
yeah anyone can
anyone can visit that right now and
explore all of our
predictions um
yeah i think i'll just skip this just
for time
uh but yeah so we also uh
noticed that others in the community had
started picking up alpha fold
for to help them with their experiments
which is a very cool sort of closing of
the loop so we found that people who've
run experiments often their data can be
noisy or quite inconclusive
and uh by looking at our predicted
outcomes for the structure it can sort
of help them
help them resolve their actual
experimental results which is a really
nice thing to see
and yeah hopefully so we can we can help
experimentalists do better experiments
which is definitely definitely the aim
uh another great thing we observed which
is something that we've not uh aimed for
at all was actually
whenever we've been presenting these
protein structures in this presentation
um we've essentially assumed that they
it has some fixed 3d structure
um
you know some some nice uh some nice
solid
conformation
but actually in nature proteins are
often quite disordered and just sort of
floppy and waving around in space and
that's actually really hard to measure
with experiments because you kind of
require it to be fixed in place
uh but what we started observing is that
um sometimes alpha fold is very
unconfident in its predictions and will
just create these big sort of uh
oops
yeah create these big sort of chains of
spaghetti almost
uh and
you know originally people were thinking
that that was maybe the algorithm just
being bad here but it turns out that
often when applefold is very unconfident
it's actually because the protein in
nature is unstructured
and yeah it's actually a disordered
protein intrinsically and so after turns
out affords confidence
is a very good predictor of whether or
not the protein is actually naturally
disordered
uh which was a really cool discovery for
us
and yeah hopefully useful for the for
the community
uh
cool yeah i think i've just got one last
small section
um
so
yeah everything we've talked about so
far has basically more or less been
proteins as these sort of uh single
single entities that kind of float
around in space as a blob but in the
real world pretty much every protein
like in order to do something or to
affect some change has to interact with
some other molecule maybe another
protein or maybe
a small drug or maybe a dna or something
like that so pretty much the world of
proteins is all about interactions
and we found that once we open sourced
the model the community found all kinds
of ways to take our sort of single chain
model and sort of hack it so it could uh
make predictions about multiple chains
together and think about protein-protein
interactions which is very cool they
mainly did it by adding sort of big
linker regions between two proteins to
sort of pretend that they're a single
protein
but that was a very cool thing to see
um
yeah and then uh yeah we said we
followed up with that because we know
that it's a
it's a um
a super useful thing for the community
we followed up with that by training our
own version which can deal with multiple
protein complexes so now we can say
things about sort of big assemblies of
of proteins
which is super important for
yeah learning about how proteins work
actually in in in nature and in the real
world
uh so hopefully that's something we can
do much much more of
uh proteins
actually
all across nature make some absolutely
giant assemblies and that's the things
that we we can't really say much about
yet but that's largely just due to uh
engineering constraints so definitely
something that we can sort of be
thinking about more in in the future
and yeah something that came out very
recently was a a huge collection of
teams there's a special issue in in
science
where uh various uh structural biology
groups have solved the structure of the
the nuclear pore complex which is a very
important large protein complex within
uh within your cells and they actually
without us being aware had made quite a
lot of use of alpha fold in uh in
solving this this doing this amazing
work uh so yeah if we if we've had some
tiny contribution to that that would be
uh absolutely incredible uh so yeah
exciting times ahead for uh yeah protein
structure prediction i would say
cool uh yeah and i think that's
everything i had to say hopefully we've
still got a bit of time for uh questions
if there are any but yeah i just wanted
to add that um all of this work is a
yeah a huge team effort and i think
that's some of the best ways to do
uh machine learning so yeah thanks to
all of these great uh collaborators and
yeah hopefully that was um
yeah an interesting interesting talk for
you all yeah thank you
thank you very much
for the interesting
[Music]
oh yeah sure yep
cool um
uh okay so the first question relates to
slide 21 i think
uh it says what is the information we
get with the the residue pairs
um
so
what i assume you might mean is um
[Music]
uh what is this um
yeah my guess as to what the question is
is
uh what is this what is the info input
information about about the residue
pairs
uh and yeah i guess that's that's
slightly confusing because we actually
have no input information about the
residue pairs uh this really you could
think of as kind of like an
initialization
of we we want to know something about
the residue pairs and we want the neural
network to discover something about the
residue pairs but at the initial point
we know nothing so you can imagine this
being initialized as an array of zeros
or something and hopefully the neural
network will paint in information there
to maybe give some intuition about what
the kind of information that might be is
so firstly i'd say these are kind of
feature vectors so it's very difficult
to say anything with certainty about it
but what you could imagine is rather
than feature vectors if for example
the network was able to
give you a scalar value for each residue
pair which might be
say the distance between each two
so say like oh this is 10 angstroms from
there and this is 10 angstroms from
there and this is 50 angstroms from
there
you in principle could then do some sort
of constraint satisfaction some kind of
optimization process to try and turn
that into a 3d structure
and that's basically what the original
alpha fold did um
in this one because we're kind of
talking fully about sort of deep
learning there's maybe not such a
there's maybe not such a interpretable
way of thinking about it but i think
those are kind of good ways those are
kind of good sort of approximations to
think about it that
it's possible from information about
residue pairs to try and then
find a structure that satisfies all that
information
and that's kind of what we're trying to
go for there it's about kind of
trying to
sculpt the neural network in such a way
that the correct answer is sort of
deducible from it
so hopefully that's
helpful um
the next question is how do we know that
the output protein is the one we want
uh is a good one and yeah that's a
that's a very important question uh i
guess so i guess the
uh i guess we can't know that for sure
uh how we know it in practice is two
ways one of them we you know do a
classic train test validation splits
that are of our training process so we
can say
okay so we've trained the network now we
can take a held out set of data predict
the structure and then measure against
the true one and see how well we've done
and so obviously that's something we can
do you know while we're training the
model
but obviously for any practical
application of this
uh we kind of can't know the answer
right because if we the only way we can
find that answer is by doing the
experiment and the entire reason the
entire point for doing this was to not
have to do the experiment
so actually this is where the uh the
confidence prediction comes in
so now we feel pretty good that
if alpha fold has
a very high confidence in its prediction
it's extremely likely that the answer is
correct and we can sort of cross
validate that on held our data and then
we can sort of
hopefully trust that for predictions on
new data
so yeah hopefully that's good
um
next one uh by transforming the
structure into triangles we admit some
atoms and the link between them
uh
don't we lose sorry i'm just scrolling
don't we lose
i guess that says information oh yeah
don't lose information uh
yeah it's a very good observation so so
actually
the the backbone of each
amino acids is made up of three atoms
um
and those three atoms are always
arranged in the same way for each amino
acid so actually with three atoms like
this we can define we can
uniquely define a reference frame aka a
triangle
um so so actually because we have
because we have some assumptions
basically about how long the bond
lengths are here
we can actually um
have a one-to-one relationship between
the backbone and the
the triangles basically without losing
any information but that's because we
know something about protein structures
aka how long the bond lengths are and
that kind of thing for the backbone uh
for the side chains i didn't really talk
about that because of time but we
we also represent those in the network
as well um and yeah we also use things
we know about how uh how proteins are
structured through that so yeah it's
possible to do this without losing
information but if if certain things
weren't true about proteins aka the bond
lengths being constant etc then you
would lose information you're right
uh why do we use transformers instead of
other architectures like cnn and gnn
uh yeah so i'd say the original version
of alpha fold
so the one from 2018 basically you did
use cnns uh the reasons why we wanted to
switch to attention-based things are
essentially because
we want uh residues to be able to
uh well we want at least the bias to be
not just that we think locally and
expand outwards we kind of want it to be
super easy for this residue to talk with
this one because maybe in the structure
it's really close
um
the reason we can't do that with a gnn
like you might do with sort of small
molecules or something like that
is because we don't actually know this
graph
up front
uh
with it with regular with sort of
more general molecule stuff it's quite
possible you already know the connected
the connectivity graph of the molecule
or you almost certainly do know it
so you can kind of bake that into your
graph net
for us we use attention because we
basically want to start with a fully
connected graph sort of everything
talking to everything and then learn
which things actually should talk to
each other so you can think of the
transformer here as a sort of soft
relaxation of a gnm
[Music]
which metrics do we use to evaluate the
model uh so there's various sort of uh
protein specific distance metrics
basically uh some called gdt some called
ldt
uh which are basically sort of yeah
protein-specific ways of comparing two
structures and looking at the distance
between them you could just look at
something like an rmsd
between all the coordinates but there's
some there's and and we do also do that
but there's some uh there's there can be
some issues with that which make it less
useful
uh
next question uh the predicted structure
is a unique and new one uh
yes and no
um so
yeah in principle you would expect
in principle you would expect the
structure from
a new sequence
to be not fully identical to um
an existing protein but often structures
are very similar to other existing ones
so for example the example i gave of
like a hemoglobin protein in a dog a cat
a human or whatever all the sequences to
these might be a little bit different
but the structure
might ultimately be extremely similar
because it's still trying to do the same
thing in nature
and so evolution will basically have
conserved say like okay this sequence
can maybe change a bit but it shouldn't
change the resulting structure because
we want this molecule to do the same
thing
so um i'd say you know down to atomic
levels of detail the structure is unique
but quite often you see things that are
um
quite often you see the um
uh
similar things oh okay i see the
question has changed um but yeah so in
principle yeah there should be
more or less there's some subtlety to it
but a single sequence as far as alpha
fold is concerned a sequence uniquely
maps to a structure
but in nature these things aren't just
fixed blobs they might move around a bit
and have some dynamics
and so
that's not something that offer fold
captures
uh another question
uh
i do not clearly understand how the
amino acid sequence is passed onto the
models
uh is it
as an image graph text um
sorry i wouldn't say
oh right uh so so yeah so the amino acid
sequence you can think of it passed as
uh yeah as text essentially so you can
imagine it basically as a
set of tokens like with text and we can
pass as uh um
as a like as a one hop basically on text
uh if that makes sense so so a one-hot
encoding of the amino acids is the input
uh did you include african dna in your
experiments uh yeah so the so pretty
much all of the data set we use is the
the sort of sum total of all sequenced
dna
uh across you know
not just across humans but across all
sort of species all of all of nature
so
as in general we've just tried to use as
much of the the sequenced data that
exists
i'm sure that there exists biases within
uh
what kind of sequencing has been done
historically but as far as we're
concerned we just use all all available
data
next question
why do we need the triangular inequality
constraint uh so i'd say it's not so
much that we need it
but i would say it's uh it's something
which seems to make sense in terms of
trying to enforce
trying to force the network to think in
a certain way almost to think about the
representations that it makes
should be um yeah self-consistent and i
mean i guess the true the true answer to
this which is true of lots of deep
learning stuff is um
uh that it worked better we tried it and
it increased the performance and i think
that's true of uh
i think that's true of uh yeah almost
everything in deep learning
uh why do the multiple sequence
alignment matrix entries like columns
and rows have different functions
um
[Music]
so
uh so in principle
in principle uh the i'm not sure exactly
what you mean by different functions
but
the idea is kind of that all of the rows
should have the same function in that
all of the rows should correspond to
like the same protein in a different
species or some like small mutation of
the of the original thing so the idea is
um
the idea is that
we align them as well so each column
should represent
like should be aligned to the
the input sequence
and so the rows the columns should
basically like how does this residue
vary
in evolution
uh yeah sorry maybe that's not too
helpful but yeah i don't think i quite
followed the question
uh and yeah this next one
uh yeah sorry i don't quite understand
the question is is the way of encoding
the sequences
oh uh
so yeah maybe you mean the same as this
question above how do we encode the
sequences
um
and yeah this is basically just done
with a sort of one hot encoding similar
to how you might do it in natural
language except your your set of tokens
is just your amino acids rather than
yeah letters or bite-pairing codings or
something
um what is the difference between
alcohol and alpha 2 in model structure
um
so
with the original alpha fold
the model was basically a big
convolutional neural network
and what it did was predict the pairwise
distances between each residues and then
there was an optimization phase which
produced a 3d structure sort of separate
from the neural network
with alpha fault 2
the model is sort of end to end a big
sort of transformer style model so we've
gone from convolutions to transformers
and we've also gone from a sort of
two-step approach to just a single model
and yeah i think both of those two
things were were very important for the
big sort of change in performance
uh yeah really great questions thank you
everyone
yeah um oh yeah new question
is there a new model that performs more
perfectly than uh perfectly more than
our fault two uh
as far as i'm aware no um i i think as
it stands there's um you know i don't
think anything
has uh has done better than alpha fold
two yet uh you know i'm sure in the
future we'll see uh more improvements
and um
yeah it'll be great great to see that uh
but as far as i'm aware nothing has um
uh nothing has outperformed it so far
um but i mean you know we've we've fully
open sourced the code and the weights so
it's there for anyone to try and build
upon and try and improve on so we'd we'd
love to see that